yeah we rehearsed the fight scenes but
most of them were just me getting my ass
kicked
never back down
it was the sidekick ya know the kind of
guy who he videotaped everything and I
couldn't fight so it's like he's kind of
this like one of the kind of guy which
felt like me American Horror Story when
I first started American Horror Story I
had no idea what it was a lot of this
stuff in it you know in the pilot you
find out that Tate is a ghost and in the
series you don't find out till episode 4
or 5 I love the character I mean it's
it's in the character description it
said you don't know if he's gonna kiss
or kill you which I was like huh that's
kind of weird and interesting and and
the way it was written I mean there's
there's a line about you know in Indian
blood and like you know he was talking
about the dream that he had and he's
like I like that and the way I did that
I remember Ryan told me you know years
later he was like because of the way you
said that line that's why you got the
role and I was like oh cool I wasn't I
was a really thinking about that wine
probably season 1 was probably my
favorite season because you don't and we
need we'd like to say we didn't know
what it was I didn't know it was gonna
be an anthology series I didn't know I
was gonna be playing a different role I
I didn't know anything I was just happy
to have a job and happy to have a cool
part you know being in a in a show that
was you know intense and sort of you
know flipped everything on its head
which was cool so I I didn't know any of
that stuff going into it we do a lot of
crazy stuff
I remember in season 5 when I was when I
was mr. March
I was sawing body parts off and then the
countess comes in I'm like darling this
whole thing and it was just it was one
of those moments where I stepped outside
of myself to looked at what I was
actually doing and it was kind of
disgusted and horrified and was like
I've become kind of a desensitized to
this stuff which is really weird and and
kind of gross so I was one of those
weird surreal moments
how was the outside darling tell me
about one of your recent kills I don't
know how I developed the voice I just
kind of I was watching a lot of William
Powell for like a 1930s voice you and I
have friends I feel a certain
responsibility to you and it sort of
just kind of came from there you know I
just started messing around with it and
then once you hear it then you start
getting into it and then and then you
get more scripts and more dialogue and
you start to play around with that and
see if it works and if it's weird or or
not and and it was just fun I just love
I love playing that hobby said my
favorite is to work with Sarah because
she's just so funny and so sweet and and
you know she she's a great actress but
she can also turn it on and off so she's
very funny and and sweet in between
takes and on set and stuff so it's fun
to joke around with her and Colt last
year I got to play a lot of crazy
characters Jim Jones David Koresh doe or
do we never quite figured it out from
Heaven's Gate Jesus Manson that was the
other one yeah I got to play Manson that
was really intense I did a lot of
research on those guys shooting that
show is absolute insanity we should have
an American Horror Story season in space
it's it would be cheap because you could
do it contained you know in the space
station or ship or whatever it may be
and then there's some kind of crazy
creature or people are start to go
insane and there's like you know you
could do a lot of social commentary - it
could be could be fun it could be really
good
Bryan Singer had seen me in an American
Horror Story and you know called me up
and and offered me the part of
Quicksilver that was a dream come true
you know I love the x-men movies growing
up and I was a big fan of Bryan's and
and and all the actors and characters
and the x-men movies I was like yes
immediately I didn't even read anything
or anything he just kind of told me it
was I was really fast and that was it
and I was in there's this one scene
where my character runs around and
everybody's frozen and it's you know
it's basically just me with a green
screen I was just excited to get in
there and do it and then when they
showed me when I was gonna be doing and
they showed me the the previous the
sequence of it with time in a bottle of
the song I thought it was kind of
hilarious and just a really fun way to
show the superpower the cast is
incredible they're all you know a list
actors so it was kind of it was a dream
come true working with them - Hugh
Jackman is great I remember we were
shooting that scene in my basement he
kind of he doesn't he pulls his claws
out and they're like these gross like
they're not they're not the usual metal
claws that I was used to seeing and of a
bone claws and they looked kind of
gnarly and gross and sorry I kind of owe
it in rehearsal and Hugh was really cool
and it was like a do that do that I was
like okay cool
so I did it and then it ended up in the
movie which is uh which is cool
the Dark Phoenix is gonna come out
sometime
I think either end of this year or next
year it's a full-on
drama it feels like to me you know it's
it's very like the title says dark and
emotional and it's about you know the
inner struggle of Jean and Phoenix we
would shoot it in the summer so you go
back in the summer of Montreal that's
just kind of like summer camp you know
you just go there and you see the gang
again and you're you're on set and it's
long hours and you're in some sort of
weird you know
rubber suit but everybody's hilarious
and I mean they're truly some of the
funniest people I've ever met yeah you
just laugh your ass off so it's it's
really fun working on those films
so in American animals I play war and
Lipka the fire I guess behind the
operation warns the I don't know he's
kind of the like the trickster or like
the shaman of the group you know he's
this kind of crazy guy who gets off on
you know planning a meat heist you know
where he steals meat that's left over
from the restaurant that he works at so
it's like it's he's he's kind of this
fun character that that is just trying
to get the most out of life and to feel
alive yeah the film is based on true
events there's actually the real guys in
the movie with us so the inner cut
between the documentary and the
narrative version so it sounds weird but
it actually does work and he uses the
documentary footage as sort of a an
anchor really to the truth of the story
so you're you're you're watching this
film and and you know sometimes when you
watch this is based on a true story you
end up questioning it and go how much of
this is you know Hollywood and is it
really true and when those moments
happen it cuts back to the real guys and
you realize that it's coming straight
from their mouths and and it all is
really true and and how it happened so
it's it's an incredible story it's an
incredibly true story before we started
shooting our American animals Bart he
sent us video footage would you see in
the film he sent to us and also sent us
more than that which sort of gave us an
idea of who they were and where they
came from and why they did it and sort
of where they were at when it all took
place but it wasn't enough for me and
and I was furious that he didn't want us
to talk to the real guys which was so
frustrating and annoying because like
that's the best part
like he's right there I can I can I can
go to him I can be like hey what
happened here and you know it did happen
10 years ago so I understand where Bart
was coming from in terms of not wanting
us to have our performance shaped by
them with their hindsight and trying to
sort of maybe save face you know so I
got it but I also thought it would have
been really fun hanging out with him
Deadpool - yeah we did that cameo and I
thought it was gonna be at the end for
the credits you know something silly so
we all there was some really hilarious
not PG versions of him opening that door
and we're all in there doing some insane
stuff and it actually ended up being in
you know kind of the first half of the
movie which is pretty cool
I that's another dream of mine I'd love
to be a part of the Deadpool movies
thanks for sitting here listen to me
Yammer on about my characters that was
part one hopefully in five years I'm
still working and we can see a part two